Hey youtubers it's Charlie and my friends
at Geek and Sundry are building the Fairy
Bow from Ocarina Of Time and Nintendo just
revealed the new Zelda for Wii U coming next
year so I wanted to do a breakdown of the
gameplay footage they showed off and the lore
behind my top 5 items in the franchise. Just
like Final Fantasy, the Zelda games have pretty
good continuity when it comes to in game items
and backstory. There's a few small differences
that I'll talk about for each item. And I'll
post a link in the description for the build
video so you guys can watch Nika make the
bow.
So first things first. Zelda Wii U, the trailer
was really short and because nintendo is hardcore
about not using their footage on youtube I'm
just going to use screencaps but here's what
it looks like. The game is coming in 2015.
They didn't specify if it was spring or winter
but the biggest change to the mechanics is
the way you interact with the environment.
It's going to be a lot more like a next gen
RPG game where there is a story to follow,
but there aren't really any boundaries in
the game like previous installments. It's
like one continuous world, you don't instance
into new areas so the game is just loading
new environment continuously as you travel.
Boss fights and encounters have also been
changed accordingly. As you enter new areas
you randomly encounter enemies and bosses
have patrol areas like an MMO.
It's a big change for the series, so let me
know if you like that the Zelda games are
going to start behaving more like MMOs or
if you prefer the classic mechanics.
The gameplay footage looks amazing and I might
have to buy a wii U now. Shut up and take
my rupees.
This all reminds me of when Ocarina of Time
came out and melted everyone's brains. Ocarina
of Time was the first Zelda game to come to
n64 and I remember it hit right at christmas
break from school so everybody from school
just disappeared for two weeks into their
basements so they could play the whole thing
through. Of all the zelda 64 titles this is
my favorite to replay.
So here are my top 5 favorite items from the
franchise and some of the lore behind them.
Number 5 - The Goddess's Harp
In the timeline of the franchise the first
time Link gets this is in Skyward Sword as
a child, but it's also used by Princess Zelda
in Ocarina of Time and you could argue that
it's almost the same thing as the Harp of
Ages in the Oracle series on Gameboy Color.
In Skyward Sword it functions a lot like the
Ocarina of Time in that it helps you unlock
new challenges in the game. But in the actual
Ocarina of Time game Zelda only uses the Goddess
Harp to teach you new Ocarina songs. So in
each game the same items get used in different
ways even though the lore is similar.
As the name implies the Harp comes from the
goddess Hylia she was the goddess who stayed
behind to guard the triforce when the old
gods left Hyrule. She eventually chose to
take mortal form and became the progenitor
for the Hyrulian Royal family.
In the franchise she became the first incarnation
of Zelda in skyward sword, but for example
in Ocarina of Time the Zelda we meet is her
descendant. In all of the games the royal
family descends from the goddess' bloodline
though.
The first time we actually met the gods was
in Ocarina of Time, but subsequent games continued
to feature them.
Number 4 - The Silver Arrow
Next to the master sword this is one of the
most important items in the franchise. In
the original NES games you use it to kill
Ganon at the end, and in later games in the
franchise they turned it into Light Arrows.
But they serve the same function. They also
cause enemies to drop hella extra rupees.
In Twilight Princess you don't actually get
to use them, but Zelda does and they serve
the same function.
In the lore they're generally just magical
arrows that literally pierce evil. In some
of the later games you find them in dungeons.
But in Ocarina of time Zelda keeps them in
the sacred realm until you wake all of the
sages.
After Ocarina the sages were incorporated
into all aspects of the franchise. They serve
as the bridge between the sacred realm where
the triforce is kept and the physical world
of Hyrule.
Number 3 - The Magic Mirror
This only appears in Link to the Past and
you use it to travel between the light and
dark worlds but you can also use it as a warp
device inside dungeons. You obtain it by helping
the Lost Old Man. That's the only name he's
given, but in the lore he's a descendant of
the sages and you eventually have to rescue
his daughter who's one of the seven maidens.
They're a group that appears in both Link
to the Past and the Four Swords games. In
each of the installments you have to rescue
them.
You also learn about the power of the mirror
from Sahasrahla who's also a descendant of
the sages and helps teach you things
in the game.
Number 2 - The Hylian Shield
In the game it's the most powerful shield
you can get and also protects you from fire.
Usually the shield is purchased but Skyward
Sword introduced some more creative Lore.
It's guarded by the dragon Lanayru who's one
of three sacred guardians appointed by the
goddess to watch over parts of Hyrule.
The shield itself is most famous for it's
appearance. All incarnations of the franchise
have used the same based symbols which incorporate
aspects of the Goddess Crest, The Royal Crest
and the Hylian Crest. It bears the Triforce
and the Crimson Loftwing. It's always been
on the shield, but just like the dragon Skyward
Sword also turned the loftwing into an actual
bird you get bonded to like Daenerys is bonded
to her dragons on game of thrones.
and my number 1 favorite item of Course - The
Master Sword
I think my favorite animation in the series
is still Link yanking the master sword out
in the temple of time during Ocarina. The
sword was originally forged by the goddess
as the goddess sword and then is later reforged
into the master sword by Link.
It's imbued with the spirit of Fi who is a
humanoid spirit representation of the goddess
and gives you tips that help you complete
your quests.
Skyward Sword really takes the lore a lot
further and incorporates a dark version of
the sword weilded by Demise. But it's implied
that the goddess and the sages forged the
Goddess and Master Swords as a result of Demise
creating his version of the sword.
It's a very chicken or the egg type argument
that gets even more complicated when the game
incorporates time travel.
Even though I've always thought of the Hero's
Bow and Light Arrows as the most important
weapon in the franchise, the Master Sword
is still the most identifiable in game item.
Probably because of arthurian mythology and
excalibur.
But now it's your turn. Let me know which
Zelda game is your favorite and whether or
not you're planning on getting Zelda Wii U
when it comes out.
I'll probably do a few more bonus lore videos,
so feel free to suggest games. Like I said,
be sure to check out Geek and Sundry's build
video, they actually make a real life version
of the hero bow.
You can click here to get it and click here
for my other lore videos.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
high fives!